[Music]
not the best way to start out the
holiday season as one local business in
the southwest Valley had their property
stolen right outside their front door
now they're asking for the Public's help
not only to find their missing trailer
but the jet ski that was inside of it
Madison Kimbrough is in the southwest
Valley tonight with this story
the owners of this furniture shop that
you see behind me here on Dean Martin
Drive say they parked their trailer in
this parking lot Friday afternoon and
then hours later around 9 pm it was gone
we're hoping for the best but it uh you
know it's all time time will tell but
it's just unfortunate that stuff like
this is going on I mean this is a busy
road
it you wouldn't think that that would
happen we often don't think it'll happen
to us having our belongings stolen out
of plain sight but that's what happened
to locals in Rico Cairo and his mother
Jody who owned brick and mortarless
Furniture in the southwest Valley I had
the trailer parked here with my jet ski
ready to take it over to a spot to store
it and I came back in the morning and
the trailer and everything was gone
their brand new jet ski was a black and
green Yamaha GP 1800r Enrico's sharing
the security footage with 8 news now of
the incident and as you can see a black
pickup truck is in the parking lot and
while it never shows the truck driving
away with the trailer Cairo is certain
that whoever's driving the truck is the
thief Enrico's mom Jody Cairo says this
couldn't have happened at a worse time
since they're preparing to move store
locations but acknowledges that now
without a doubt they will be more
Vigilant moving forward to think that's
something that could happen that fast I
believe somebody had to have been
watching the lighting is very important
and we will we will have better security
and better cameras as of now a police
report has been filed and of course if
you know the whereabouts of this jet ski
or trailer you were urged to contact
Metro immediately the Cairo family is
offering up a one thousand dollar reward
reporting in the southwest Valley
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now